from UD Austin for the last talk of
today and after this we'll be having an
open problem session at 3 30 after
taking a break yeah so Sunday is an I
triple fellow president of numerous
precise Awards including the IEEE
communication societies William Bennett
price today I'll be talking about power
of adaptivity representation learning
thank you very much um it's uh it's a
privilege to speak here and thank you to
ship around Balu for inviting me to this
Workshop so you have seen these words
over the last several days at least in
passing meta learning in the context of
reinforcement learning and then
yesterday Federated learning in the
context of Bandits so there's very very
different algorithms both which are very
useful people have used a lot so what is
the connection between them is something
I'd like to explore a little bit in the
context of representation learning so
this joint work where the lead student
uh lead author is Liam Collins your
graduate student doing his PhD at UT
Austin my colleague Aryan mukhari and
also in collaboration with two of uh
with Hamad Hassani who's at UPenn and
saving at UW
foreign
so let me start with the sort of the the
overview is so one of the one of the
goals when you try to train a model is
to generalize the new tasks meaning
suppose you have so there are some
random background images though there's
a background of ocean or a desert or a
mountain or a forest there's something
which is taking pictures in various
locations and you want to identify
targets say a human or something like
that okay so you have a little bit of
data from each one of these settings but
what you really want is for you to
suppose the classification problem you
want to solve this in a new setting so
meaning maybe some other background and
you still want things to work well so
the goal is not use the real goal is you
want to use all your training to find a
model which is generalizable that's
that's really one of the central goals
of machine learning okay
um one of the flavors of this problem
I'm going to stick to this flavor for
today's talk completely this is notion
of few short learnings so the few short
learning setting is a following suppose
that you have in aggregate large amounts
of data from many environments so
meaning that from each one of your many
many environments and for me each one
you have a little bit of data you put
all these together you have humongous
about this data okay
um but you also have a small amount of
data prior to deployment meaning when
you come to this setting maybe you can
collect a few samples maybe enough to do
a few steps of gradients if you want to
retrain your model to find clean your
model okay so that's broadly the setting
I'm going to be in for the entire talk
so one possible approach then is to
build a model using data from the
training environments using your
favorite method and then fine tune the
model meaning run a few steps of
gradient descent on the model which can
just optimize some of the parameters
before deployment this is what lots of
people do this is the generic this is
the standard practice in machine
learning
and so
you want to if you if you're going to
fine tune the
fine tunable
this describes basically what I talked
about so I'm from now on I'm going to
talk about environments as tasks just to
be compliant with the Lang standard
language in the city so a bunch of tasks
in each task a task essentially means
that the data distribution is different
or equivalently if you look at the
infinite the loss function is different
is the expectation with respect to a
different data distribution okay
um so you've got a bunch of different
tasks these images are about digit
classification maybe colored backgrounds
some other handwriting yet another
handwriting and so on so you have some
some number of samples from each one of
these so associated with each task is a
different last function and what you
want to do is to find a model that will
minimize the average loss across all
these tasks and then what you do you get
this model and then once you have this
model you a new task is revealed and you
get a few samples from that you do a few
gradient steps I've just written one
gradient you could do a free whatever
data you have you do you use a few few
gradient steps you get a new model and
then you test your model on this that
this is just a pictorial representation
of exactly what I see okay
does this work well okay this is what we
will call this arm plus fine tuning arm
meaning average risk minimization plus
fine tuning and so suppose you have
images from a large number of classes
then a task is essentially classifying
images from a cave subset so if you have
c400 for example you have 100 classes of
images maybe different types animals
maybe birds so on and this task task one
is to classify between dogs deer and
frogs task two between Birds horses and
cats and so on they're all different
problems but there is some underlying
representation that is common these are
all images of natural objects okay so
potentially there's something you can
learn across all this so what you would
do is you'd have minimize the average
loss across all these tasks then when
you're given a new three set you want to
optimize your modifier well thank you
and
if you just do this by the default
average minimization and fine tuning
it's known that this has mixed
performance going like this back to a
paper or the mammal paper by Finn Nabil
and Levine in 2017. they observed that
this doesn't have great performance
um again empirically and
so they therefore you want to do
something different to actually make
this work okay there are some one of two
things you can do in this talk we'll
talk about this one is change the loss
function in some Manner and that leads
to something called mammal okay
um or you can change the training
procedure which shows a very interesting
connection to Federated learning so this
is not the way you think you don't think
of Federated learning as a way of
looking for
um for improving arm but we will have an
interesting interpretation of that in
the second part of this talk
okay so what is mammal
mammal or model agnostic matter learning
is the following this is I'm summarizing
the results by uh often a bill at all
this paper so it's exactly the same
picture I put up earlier okay you've got
a bunch of tasks and you want to find a
model
previously the model was to minimize the
average loss
instead of minimizing the average loss
mammal says
you're going to fine tune this model
anyway and plot
so why do you work with that you should
really consider the model post fine tune
so for example for this task
suppose that the optimization procedure
results in a model Theta Theta tilt up
okay you're not going to use Theta tilde
you're going to take the Theta tilde
take a few gradient steps with F1
with this loss function and then use
that so as well as train a model for
that objective
change the objective I want some meaning
because so this is just an optimization
the change in the optimization problem
is the following instead of minimizing
fi of theta
you want to minimize f i of theta minus
a few gradient steps I've written just
one gradient step here you could do what
if maybe five radial steps so this is
really the difference this is our
original objective function mammal said
the new model has been personalized for
each task so as well as look at the
personalized model and then minimize the
average risk that's all there is to it
so it's an it's a completely
optimization perspective and this once
you have this model and you come to a
new deployment setting you fine tune
with respect to the specific loss
function you're going to see take a few
gradients inside the plot yeah
here's some intuition why those are
different but you think the average
assassins so why are these laws
functions there so there are two why the
loss function difference or why the the
results are different
okay good it seems to work very well in
practice deals so Empire so first of all
empirically that's true it doesn't there
are several uh
there are several sort of
interpretations of this let's think
about this from just an initialization
point of view suppose the loss functions
are actually just a couple of quadratics
okay okay one which is sort of which has
a very um which is sort of sharp and the
other which is not
what does that mean that means one of
them has if you take a gradient step the
model will not move very much in the
other one the model can move a lot so
where should we initialize it you know
the initialize it closer to the harder
task so that when you actually update
um you can you can sort of fit for both
these different loss functions so this
image this com this is a landscape
interpretation we are going to talk
about a different interpretation but
this this is one way of thinking about
it just from optimization yeah
we're extraordinary Anderson because
right now you you have this kind of
taking one gradient and then with this
minimization this is like either there
will be since you are minimizing there
will be another great idea yeah so in
this related but uh maybe we can talk
about that option yeah right now I
I I'm not trying to this talk we're not
trying to propose any algorithm just try
to understand what is going on but from
a generalization point of view or not an
optimization
so the explanation I gave you is sort of
an optimization Viewpoint that I want to
find a good initialization from which I
can move easily to every one of the
tasks or when I actually see the task
foreign
[Music]
classification for regression for RL and
so on
but in 20 there's this interesting paper
by Raghu Raghu Benji or Nina's which
shows that even though it doesn't it's
not design for representation learning
it seems to find it and what do you mean
by that so what they did is again from
their paper
um the X the y axis here is a similarity
score
and the x-axis is a layer of a neural
network okay
they actually looked at the mod they
looked at the model trained by member
and then fine-tuned it and looked at the
model again and compared the model
before and after fine tune
so in this so what they noticed is that
early layers of this did not seem to
change very much higher is means no
change lower means change whereas the
last layer changes a lot
and their interpretation was somehow
that means it's finding some natural
representation of the underlying data
and all you're solving is the LA all
you're updating is the regression that's
the last layer if there are a
classification layer it's a very
interesting experiment of their of
theirs and this is true when you look at
so there are different ways to measure
similarity I'm not going to get into
that for neural networks but across
different ways of looking at it this is
what they observe
so why is this so that's what we want to
talk about in the first part of the
stock can we do we have some theoretical
theoretical view of this product
so we are going to look at it in the
simplest possible setting the multitask
linear regression so the model is the
following
we have a bunch of linear regression
problems n of them each one being a task
for the ith linear regression this is
all in Rd for the ith linear regression
you've got a vector Theta star I which
is unknown and you just want to
standardize solve the standard linear
regression
nothing fancy okay
um and if you if they have no relation
to each other then we know that with
already little bit more than order D
samples if we put no other assumptions
then you should be able to find Theta
star for each problem this is just
Baseline
suppose however we plant a
representation what do we mean by this
okay let me take a matrix B Star a small
number of columns K is very small
compared to D okay and say that all
these Theta stairs lie is in the
Subspace uh defined by D star
okay
meaning Theta star can be written as
some Global Matrix B Star times a look a
k dimensional Vector W star
this is now multitasking linear
regression with the Subspace right again
nothing fancy lots of people have worked
on this I'm just setting up a model
ah
of course we know if you know the column
space of B Star then we can quickly
solve this problem with just K because
you just need to find the regression
coefficients you don't need to find D
dimensional problem you need to solve
only a k dimensional problem so with
order K samples you should be able to
solve for each task
good this is I just want to make sure
you're comfortable with the model this
just the basic model at this point
okay
there's no noise there is okay so this
is the model Theta star so I the
previous next slide I just talked about
what's the model for Theta star so still
it's a linear regression it goes in no I
see z i is just a gaussian
um Theta star which is a vector has an
underlying model these Theta starts
across these stars are not arbitrary
they all come from a common Subspace
that's the difference between the
general multitask linear regression and
this problem what do you mean that you
can solve the case
so yeah if with order km so if I project
if I know B Star
okay if I know the column space then
potentially I can sort of the order case
samples per task
maybe you're talking about because the
noise is high dimensional how do you
eliminate the noise so I've been a
little sloppy about it what you want to
what you can solve in order case samples
is the multitask linear regression
suppose I know that I have enter n
problems
and they all have noise but each one of
these problems have B Star Theta w i
star can I find if I give you the B Star
can I find all the wi Stars efficiently
and that's order K per task amortized
that's all I mean otherwise there's a
the noise issue on average yeah
absolutely so that's all I mean by order
key
but this is just to set up the problem
so we will use this if you did even if
you don't know B Star and W star but you
had n task this is a multitasking this
is this is a multitask linear regression
problem and you can solve this using
different ways so you don't know B Star
and W star you can propose some
alternating algorithm maybe to find B
there are ways to solve this by no means
are we claiming that the contribution
here is to solve this problem there are
methods which people know how to solve
this we are just using this as a vehicle
to try to understand mammal that's all
so
let us see what mammal will do in this
setting okay so the problem here is
again going back to our basic uh setting
there are a bunch of loss functions fi
the model Theta now consists of a pair
we'll call B as the body for obvious
reasons it's the easy representation and
W as the head because in the regression
setting that's all it is so we have a
body and a head and it has a saw and
there's a mean Square loss for each
model the data distribution for each one
is different each task is different
which will lead to an F5 in the
population case
ah
so what does mammal do
we call what it does is when you have a
model it will adapt the model by one or
more gradient steps so we'll just do one
gradient step in the stock okay we'll
just talk about what happens when you
just do one gradient step
so an iterative algorithm if you want to
do gradient descent this naturally reach
for a two-stage in inner and outer
gradient descent meaning at some point I
give you a model during the iteration
the model will be wtbt some head and
some body remember you're not trying to
find a bunch of models you're just
trying to find one model which is
adaptable so I have a WT and BT and you
want to update it but to update it you
first do a task specific update for each
head meaning for e if you have a WT take
a gradient step to get uh updated task
specific head look at the body take a
gradient step find an updated updated
model so with this WTI and bti you
actually have done a local update
and then you need to do a global update
because this is a task specific I need
to now take with respect to this model
for each loss I need to take a gradient
step meaning
WT plus 1 overall should be an outer
gradient descent so what I had is f of
theta minus grad f so when I actually do
an outer gradient descent you are going
to get a Hessian coming in and so on but
essentially you average across all the
tasks
um there's a gradient update there is
some pre-multiplier because you got a fi
applying both inside and outside and so
you get to an X model so this is
essentially the implementation of SGD
format yeah is it normal to split the
data
yeah so here so in
I'm going to mostly talk about the
population case so it doesn't matter
when you do concentrations the proof
will require either are the data
separate are they saying in our case for
the proofs we will have separate because
we need that for Independence
um there I thought you wanted to learn a
single BM effect of URLs but here you're
trying to learn a single BMW correct
ma'am so this was the underlying model
for the bunch of tasks and there is no
algorithm here okay all I'm saying is
suppose this is the mod this underlying
model for the end tasks
now keep this model aside this is the
this is the generative one what does
mammal what would mammal do in this
setting mammal wants to find a single B
and double okay but and how is it going
to find a single B and W for that model
this is what happens that's all I'm
saying if you do a gradient update this
is what happens this what I'm trying to
ask is why should you do member why not
try to learn a single of course that's
exactly what I'm saying if I wanted to
solve this problem there are many other
ways to solve this
um that is not what I'm trying to do
here we are just using that model as a
vehicle to understand what mammal would
do in this set that's that's all they
are doing okay
in fact you could do a whole bunch of
things and these people have done all
these things
um for example to mammal updates both
the B and double
okay people say okay why should I update
the W maybe I don't want to do an inner
loop update of a w I just want to update
the head but just an outer loot of
double this is called Anil almost no
inner loop I'm just describing the zoo
of a zoo of algorithms in this space
then there are first order algorithms
there's a hesi in here I'll just drop it
what just ignore it ignore second order
comes these are called F4 variants so
I'm just saying what this this landscape
looks like and in this landscape
therefore what you have is an inner and
out there are two levels really the
takeaways this has a two level update
algorithm in when you do a SGD an inner
update which is personalizing the model
one step and then an outer update where
you do a gradient descent after your
personality that's that's really the
takeaway from all this and going back to
this yeah if you wanted to solve that
problem there are other ways to do this
that is not the goal here at all
okay so if you do this what happens
so let's suppose you take
um you run this algorithm as a function
of iterations and the y-axis is some
um it's a metric which is the distance
between the column space at time T So at
each at time do you find a column space
BT right that's the Matrix that's it
represent representation you have at
that point and you have a head forget
the head and there's a ground truth
planted let's look at the the distance
between the the column space of BT and
the head the distance happens to be the
Principal angle distance but I'll Define
that when we actually go to the match
and subtract
if you do this what You observe is the
following
uh geometric exponentially as iterations
increase all these algorithms we do this
inner and outer loop
the the distance goes to zero very very
quickly whereas if I don't do young that
one step of gradient descent I just take
the average its minimization
the distance does not seem to go to zero
okay it's this doesn't mean the
optimistic I'm not solving the
optimization problem to zero loss I'm
looking at because there are many many
solutions right
if you do this two-step
the representation distance is going to
zero whereas for the uh for the basic
arm plus fine tune arm algorithm that's
not happening
so
there is so there is no existing theory
for any of this which is why we decided
now coming back to answer siva's
question this is the easiest model in
which we can hope to develop some Theory
okay to see why this is happening and
that's why we chose this multi this part
all right so now let's get to
um
so the data sets
they're different but related
PSI but you want to learn the common
model so that you can transform
precisely okay and with ERM are you
saying that it gets a small empirical
loss but on the column space I'll get to
that uh here all I'm in this plot all
I'm saying is
I'm not a learner like column space I'll
get to your answer if you could hold off
for about 15 minutes I get to exactly
what's going on here actually this is
not ER in this area the subtle
differences ERM is for a single task in
a multitask is an average so that's but
that's that's basically it
um so what can we show here I'll sort of
say it at a high level then dig more
into detail so on the quote unquote
standard assumptions
um we'll see what this means in a second
um mammal Anil
and the first order analogs recover the
column space of B Star and do so
geometrically fast and it's essentially
this two level update is what is uh
helps find this representation in all
directions so I basically want to learn
B stop and we'll see why that's
happening in a second and the sample
complexity though this comes with
concentrations question which alluded to
what we can prove is the following the
sample complexity for this scales as d
by D is ambient Dimension n is the
number of tasks and K is the Subspace
Dimension so what we are able to show is
d by n plus 1 times KQ so ideally you
should get K we are not able to show K
we can only get KQ but nevertheless
um you can see the ambient Dimension
even with mammal is coming down if you
use other methods just to complete the
story you could potentially do this okay
if you knew that you were trying to find
a b star going back to siva's question
you could potentially get d by n plus 1
times t
so
so this is uh this is uh day result so
let's now go back into the algorithms
itself so what we have put up there is
the team the the mammal and Anil updates
so mammal update is
you do a local update meaning if you're
at time T you have a body and a head you
do one gradient step upside uh update
that's called the inner loop in the
mammal language in the outer loop what
you do is take an outer gradient step so
there's a scn and all that stuff that
comes in this is what we talked about
just a few minutes back
ah
so if you rewrite this by substituting
what the generator model for y is and
all that you can rewrite this update in
the following form for the for the uh
for the uh for the representation so you
can rewrite this as the following at
time t plus one the column space that
you have can be written as the column
space at time T times the following
Matrix plus the true represent
representation B Star times this Matrix
now let's look at these two matrices the
first one is saying the following it is
so this is all K dimensional this is the
identity in K Dimension times which is
reduced by
um the outer product of what each
adapted head looks like in the Inner
Loop
okay so these are all rank one
if all these tasks were diverse meaning
the heads were pointing in different
spanning the low dimensional Subspace
then this would be a rank this this
thing would be ranking
okay so that means this is a full rank
Matrix
and if the scaling is correct this one
is a contractor image
um it's it's removing energy from BT
okay because I minus something
this one this is W star which is the
underlying task true model
times a WTI transpose which is what the
head looks like what each task Loop
thinks the head looks like at the
iteration
so if this is also a full ranking full
rank meaning that these things are all
pointing in different directions then
what is happening is energy is being
pulled out from BT and being added in
the B Star Direction so it is like so
it's a contraction type of thing
happening essentially and you can
imagine you can see that if there if
these are more diverse meaning the
singular value of this Matrix is away
from zero then you should geometrically
contract converge to BT so head
adaptation
dtis and diversity that these things
point in different directions
essentially is leading to geometric
contraction that's really what is going
on underneath so this is the key
intuition if you have any questions uh
uh I'll tell you the problems with this
intuition in a second but these are high
level intuition this is correct
yeah
what happened to your series
so this is the population so I have
basically taken the population limit uh
we've got rid of the stochastics and all
that stuff if you do the usual
concentrations you can need to bond all
these things and also this I've also
ignored in this the second order comes
okay it requires more work to deal with
this is a simplified version of it
so what should say just take the update
and then play around with algebra you
get this and then you set this nice
intuition for this but
I mean without having to without having
done the algebra I don't see where this
is coming from because mammals seem very
simple trick of replacing F of theta
with the F of theta minus gradient then
how are you getting this intuition of
that
foreign
there is no underlying true
representation I just made two
quadratics so mammal intuition is not
the previous intuition is not coming
from representation love me it's been
coming from essentially an
initialization now what we have done
here in this model is
to put this circum this
so I told you that these tasks are
related to this common Subspace and then
seeing what mammal does in this context
okay so this will come back to something
I'll talk about in the end which is
suppose you don't have an underlying so
mammal really is we need to think about
it in two different regimes I think one
is when you have a representation does
it actually learn it and two when you
don't have a representation what happens
the other person
is I guess you'll still show this but uh
like there is no reason why like the
whole intuition you presented is based
on that this is full right but somehow
you have to show this
and I
stop zero without a start just to make
sure everybody's on this thing Perfect
You're anticipating my next slide
actually okay oh
yeah
yeah
okay uh so can I just finish this and
get back okay
what does this update look like there's
no inner outer loop just a Super Service
just do the gradient and rewrite and
what happens and the population
Limitless
BT plus one is BT times this Matrix this
is a 9 to 1 Matrix
there is no okay because there's just
one WT and BT that's evolving when you
do arm
okay and when you do the signal the
other side B Star is multiplied by W
star WT transpose even if W stars are
diverse WT can be pulled out and this is
just a rank this is a vector so this is
also rank one so arm essentially does a
rank K minus 1 update on BT and a rank 1
update on the signal rate which means at
best this representation can move to
this can update only in One Direction
and it's not even clear it will span all
directions over time now you need to
wait for time diversity to help you at
all if it does and it does not we will
actually prove that uh you can get stuck
okay I'll get to that later
uh you don't just okay good so and now
now you can start seeing why this might
happen that arm does not converge this
is a stuck example whereas any of these
inner outer Loops do Converge All right
so now getting back to shift plus
question so what is
so does this actually happen if if I
mean I was we were saying something
about the full Rank and so on but
there's no proof of that
it's it's a hope more than a proof at
that stage okay so let's look at the
inner loop update and write a do Algebra
on this
so inner loop is
best step to update
you write it
basically what you get is the following
you will get um you will get basically I
minus BT transpose DT so think of this
as how well conditioned The Matrix BT is
if it's very well conditioned
sorry
yeah this is quite lost this I'm just
doing quadratic subgranted problem it's
all for that so if this Matrix is well
conditioned hopefully this is small
this is something common what you really
want if you want to hope that these are
divers is this part is small and this
part is large
intuitively this is how well conditions
BTS
this one says how much energy of BT is
there in the first uh
BT transpose B start you want B Star to
be well aligned with B uh BT to be well
aligned with B Star okay the if it's not
very well aligned this is going to be
small okay so it has so you're hoping
that BT actually does get better and
better and gets close to B Star if you
do if these things happen then there's
hope at least on one side of it the wtis
are diverse and that is really the
critical thing we needed if Okay so
to show that this unique part dominates
we need to show at least you don't need
to show this there may be other proofs
we will show we will show The Following
things happen that this one is well
conditioned meaning this two Norm of
this is small
WT is also small okay
um and the singular value of this is
lower bounded then there is hope that
things that things will work essentially
we can push everything through
[Music]
this one yeah
so if you look at the if I write the
update for WTI it is WT minus one
gradient step algebra basically just for
the squared loss function I need the
population setting you can rewrited
because why is there a unique part
because it's f i not F that's why that's
a unique part
that unique part comes because that one
gradient step that's happening so you
see you're not moving very much you're
just moving a little bit which is why
it's important there's not that much
movement happening so you need to for
this all this to work out you need to
show that given that little movement is
enough for everything to work out and
then there's there's enough diversity so
that that geometric convergence happens
okay so you want to show shared part is
small and the unique part is
um and coming back to coming back to
what how we'll measure the distance
something called the principal angle
distance
um essentially this is a generalization
of two vectors you look at the angle
between them if that's small it's Unique
for subspaces there is some
generalization of it called single of
something called the principal angle
distance it's basically the following
you look at two matrices which are also
normalized if you have B1 and B2 also
normalize it and look at the uh two Norm
of B1 after orthonormalizing D1
transpose B2 okay we can get into this
offline but the geometry is more
interesting that essentially if the
column space are the same then the zero
and it does it's smooth okay that's
really all that I need to worry about
here
here's the theorem statement
um in the population case meaning
infinite samples suppose that the true
ground truths are well conditioned May
are diverse meaning W star double star
transpose the average is lower and upper
bounded by mu star Square I and L star
Square I and with appropriate six sub
sizes so there's no decaying Stepside
there's all six step size business then
the distance between the the represent
at time T and B Star the true
representation the converges
geometrically and there are conditions
for each one of these things which are
different I don't want to get into it I
have 25 minutes I want to talk a little
bit about the proof and also about
Federated average so we want to show
these three things that um that
this thing is small WT does not the WT
is also small which is the average head
at each iteration and BT is getting
close to B Star
to do that he's messy okay Siva is
laughing okay it's for obvious reasons
okay
um so let's look at two different things
in this uh in this thing we want to
track two things I said that really the
intuition is that BT is well conditioned
so let's track that through this delta T
this is I minus b t transpose B how the
column how the energy in this columns in
the column space of BT you want energy
to be nice in all directions okay that's
uh that's what this is tracking and this
is tracking how diverse these wtis are
after one step okay which is decided so
this is diverse heads means this is nice
um well conditioned means this is small
okay
there are several so look at this update
you want to show WT is small this is
this delta T is small and BT B Star is
large enough
there are several problems here you'd
hope that WT shrinks as time progresses
it doesn't it actually grows so you need
to
um all many of these problems become
trivial if I could change the algorithm
and chapter each iteration I will
renormalize it I'll put some regularizer
and all that we don't have that we are
just trying to understand an algorithm
not design an algorithm okay which is
why all this mess comes in we don't have
any of the usual regularizers to just
keep track of it we just need to see
what happens here so WT grows so
induction hypothesis one is WT always
remains small
this will happen hopefully if some error
terms are summable so that's what we
need to see
second that we would like delta T to
decrease geometrically fast that's how
well conditioned it is uh it's well
conditioned the smaller it is the better
condition
it isn't true but what is true is the
following that is sort of contractive
rho is something less than one but
there's an error term that doesn't that
goes down as long as BT gets close
enough to be started okay the distance
between DT and B Star gets this thing
because it's not enough to just have a
well-conditioned representation you want
to find the right well conditioned
representation okay
um third is that even when it's doing
all these wonky things like going up and
down it never blows up too much the
condition okay that's the third step
fourth coming back to BT you want to
show that the energy of BT in the park
space to the column space of B Star is
not going to in fact it's Contracting
and that's we do have that which is
important and finally of course what we
want to show the geometric decrease so
it leads to the six-way induction which
is
um Baroque and horrible I'm sorry but
true okay
um I have uh I'll just give you a flavor
of the kinds of things that are needed
for this induction this induction has
two types of induction one from time P
to t plus one another within time T
itself to later in t okay
now you see what I mean like I'm into
Baroque problems
um yeah
so
for example uh one flavor of this if you
want to show that uh that that uh the
distance is linearly converging then you
want to show that it's well conditioned
and this so uh this this signal energy
is the heads are diverse enough that was
the basic intuition we started with
that's one step of the induction if you
have those two properties then things
remain diverse another step of the
induction if WT is small and this is
small and this is big enough then some
this this thing is diverse enough and
that's another piece of this induction
okay so these induction hypotheses are
all set up such that these things happen
the hardest part of this induction is
this this one which is to show that the
energy in WT the average head is
increasing but it doesn't blow up and
this happens because they are basically
because the principal angle distance is
geometrically converging which means
some error terms are summable and this
essentially allows they had to be
bounded energy hey that's all I want to
say but just to give a flavor of sort of
is essentially a a
an iteration argument where some energy
is going down at the highest level the
zero thought intuition and but to make
that work there are all these moving
Parts you need to take care of okay
um
so I have 15 minutes left
I will skip some of the more nuances of
mammal and uh so I talked about things
about mammal and Anil and so on now you
can ask about what's the difference in
analysis each one I'm going to skip that
I just want to sort of move to Federated
learning uh in the last 15 minutes okay
so okay so this is this is about why
there is one explanation at least in the
linear setting when there's a plantar
representation why these algorithms seem
to find good representations okay
so going stepping back all the way to
the beginning
we were training a single model in the
first part we change the loss function
by doing some gradient step and then uh
but going back to arm just minimize the
average loss fine too this is a summary
of where we started from
if you want to implement this in a
distributed manner then that leads to
Distributors gradient descent or
stochastic gradient descent which is the
following
you have a model you want to take a
gradient step instead for each each
client quotient code is a loss function
you do one gradient step send it back
average it it's just a way of writing
what we graded there's nothing fancy
going on this is an implementation of
what we talked about of AI okay so
that's what we have so far if you just
Rewritten arm this way
Federate now coming to Federated
learning what is Federated learning does
something like this
you have an arms update you send it to
you clients do a gradient step update
but instead of doing one gradient step
update
the clients do several gradient step
updates say in general maybe Tau
gradients maybe two okay one is just
distributed SGD but when you do more
than one update something funny happens
if the data distributions or the loss
functions are different then the model
diverts some more when you average it
it's not clear what has happened
okay
um the motivation for Federated learning
if I was going to talk about Federal
learning is a completely different story
it's about communication efficiency you
want to do this because you want to add
the clients have the data if that's a
privacy story or
um and then you want to minimize the
amount of back and forth so since they
have a reasonable amount of data it's
just doing one step back and forth you
may do five steps back and forth or
something like that meaning send a model
they take several gradient steps send
the model back average it and send it
now when once you put more than one step
this equivalent is no longer arm and uh
these two diverge okay that's really the
takeaway and these are the loan problem
drift so this is what people call drift
with data heterogeneity meaning the
local gradients are no longer aligned
with the global gradient so it's not
clear exactly what's going on and people
have spent a lot of energy on this this
problem okay
um people recognize this uh that there
is local drift they will not that fed I
have doesn't even solve the global
objective problem maybe uh these are
some of the references in that space and
so to control this drift there's again a
bunch of regularizers you can do to sort
of bring the drift down or something
like that by drift I mean that you are
not solving the right model but you'd
still like to take several steps of
iteration okay but fine the implicit
takeaway is essentially this new
implementation has changed out you could
think of it as solving some other
problems not clear what problem you're
trying to solve but it's solving some
other problems okay what is the is that
problem any is that what what is the
effect of that okay so now
what I realize is the following in the
same that these local this this also
going back to the first part there's a
globe mammal headache inner and an outer
loop here you can think of a local and a
global update is that somehow doing any
anything interesting from a
generalization point of view okay even
though you're not solving the right loss
function so we did these experiments on
c400 so the model was trained on 80
classes and fine-tuned for the other
classes and these are accuracy after
fine-tune depending on number of
fine-tuned examples this is with
distributed SGD this is fed average so
there's no mammal anywhere in this the
only question is instead of doing one
step of local update you do multiple
steps on local update but the global
loss function we start with
is plutively the same thing of course we
know now it's not it's a because of the
multiple steps it's not clear what is
going on but at least you started the
same effects
so
what is going on is the following so
this is a problem
you want to solve this so I want to take
if I were doing one gradient step I
would take F5 minus Delta gradient of f
i and then average it that is
distributed SGD and this is just one way
of writing
what Federated averaging does is not
this look at this equation
um look at this client it's taking
multiple gradient steps meaning it
starts it's given a Theta T and then it
will find a Theta 1 t plus 1 then it
will find a Theta one t eternally let's
put another fine index okay it'll it'll
take the it will move the model but
multiple steps of gradient
yes it finds out multiple steps of
gradients send that new model the server
just averages it and sends it back then
each one takes multiple steps okay that
is the thread averaging algorithm
here are you talking to my mom
and right now
um I'm just talking about I I'll get to
the planet model in a second right now
I'm just giving an empirical observation
I haven't come to a model I get to a
model in a few
if I check increasing the number of
local objects that always have good
um we can show it helps of good
threshold he believes through all the
way through our proof is up to a certain
threshold it organisms okay I'll get to
that also in a second
okay so this was
meaning that with Federal average and
uh the number of so because sdd does
fewer steps the amount of time you
should run it and move so the data we
are doing the Apple step is comparison
in terms of data okay meaning Tau times
T is same whether you're comparing that
average NS
the other thing we do know
the following that that like the mammal
story
if I look at the sum version of a
distance this is again for a neural
network model again this is all
empirical okay
um you look at some some score higher
means closer after fine tuning and
smaller means further away and do the
model layer so early layers don't seem
to so this is with the distributed SGD
this is credit averaging and basically
you you see that it looks like at least
there is the representation layers
aren't changing as much post fine tune
so again we are going to use this model
exactly in the same way whether you do
dsgd or a Fed averaging you will find
unit before deployment okay all right so
let's go back to the same multitask
linear regression problem uh y i is
Theta star XI plus z i Theta star uh
coming is exactly the same model from
now on we have come to this model okay
our Theta star is B Star WS and we'll
assume that W Stars the the
for each task are diverse meaning they
span RK and are well conditioned
so
the informal theorem is that for any Tau
greater than or equal to 2 the FED
averaging recovers the column space of B
Star geometrically fast when learning or
when doing task population losses we
don't have we have not done finite
sample analysis of this this for the
first part we had finite sample and
population this this doesn't have
concentration this is just a population
yeah okay and
the king site is again the same kind of
thing you write the Matrix expansion you
get ugly matrices
um I don't want to get into these ugly
matrices but do some simpler version of
these argument matrices which are still
ugly but at least some interpretability
matrices
um because
you can write these are the servers what
happens at BT plus one it's BT times
some prior some Matrix
just like our previous thing our
priority plus b star times some other
Matrix when you look at this
there's hope that because there is wtis
this could remain full rank
and this has because of the local
updates
this could remain full Rank and indeed
what we can show is that local updates
and task diversity is critical meaning
discontinued remains yeah
it's working
so the first book or not so there are
two separate
thread average is not arm because of the
multiple steps of local update what we
are showing is average Rich minimization
doesn't work
Federated averaging is an approximation
to average risk with local updates
okay and the local updates is what is
critical actually for this so it's doing
the same kind of thing mammals local
updates was doing that's really what has
happened
and what do I mean by average risk
minimization doesn't work
this is the state if local I do only one
step not more than one step okay then
this is exactly average this
minimization it's a distributed version
then you can you can write the update as
rank K minus 1 just like before plus
something which is
um again the rank problem this is a rank
one so it may not converge so what we
can prove formally is the following with
look at this particular the Tau equal to
one
so consider fix any Delta you want
between 0 and a half fix any step size
any Horizon and any collection of
diversity
and start with any initialization B
knock then we can construct a b star a
planted model such that the following
thing two are true that the principal
angle distance between B naught and B
Star is Delta
but
it doesn't get too so it doesn't go too
far away from that
at time T it's at least 0.7 Delta okay
for anything so basically it is not
converged okay this is an instance this
is not General it's not true in general
we can construct an instance where does
this happen whereas for if tau is
two or more this will not happen so
that's really the point okay
um and so the I think this plot is
interesting
if you look from an optimization point
of view this is the x-axis is time
communication and the y-axis are Norm of
the gradient of the global loss
with distributed sdd you are actually
solving the right problem meaning
minimize the average average risk and so
the error is converging exponentially
faster okay this is distributed gradient
is attention that's not even stochastic
variation whereas with Federated
averaging it's not happening you're not
solving the right problem meaning the
model doesn't model is not solving the
original loss okay so from an
optimization point of view
people have realized this for a long
time and that's why all that literature
and Federate are averaging can you do
something here to move this
to make it solve the right problem or
some variant of that
but from a generalization point of view
exactly the opposite happens
this is distributed grading descent it
does not find the right plantar
representation whereas fed averaging
leaves which means the fine to have post
fine tuning performance is much better
potentially and that's what we see here
so if you look after fine tuning and
look at the performance of distributed
SGD versus federator averaging fitted
averaging seems to work very well and
this is really what motivated this whole
story because in from talking to our our
colleagues in in industry
what people think that generically do is
just do fed averaging with fine tuning
none all these sophisticated things
people at least the teams we talked to
weren't doing so we were wondering why
that is so on this is
for a very limited problem a linear
problem
we at least have an explanation
so
there are a lot of other interesting
open questions
roughly they do 10 low typical numbers
seem to be about five or ten steps
um with some mini batches so that's so
it is so in that sense this is actually
at least for the linear model this
explained
um yeah there are a bunch of other
questions which are interesting but
maybe I can hold off for the open
problem session starting from this I'll
stop at this point since I remember
thank you
yes
uh yes I did because
it's like the gradient upgrade average
it and do it you just you can there are
these objects you write the gradient to
algebra that's how it separate
and take the expectations to the
populations
so I have a I have a different question
so I think if you think of the Arn
problem
so if I had a single fi the solution is
B times w i but if I have many of them
when you take the average the solution
is so complicated you can recover Theta
B to be you'll get a bunch of solution
good this is the other thing which I
didn't talk about will recover what you
will recover is solution so that biwis
are all equal but that doesn't mean all
the B's are same correct that's fine
that's really what is
the way to think about it is what these
are doing is also essential possibility
to be common that's another value to
think about so one last thing about it
is if you run each one locally till
convergence each guy is locally
converging to beat and Supply then if
you do a single average apparently what
you have is B times the average of all
the W's suppose you know average of B
times double
I mean it's not giving a bearded
no no if each one returns have become a
w yeah you're getting an average of
being an average of w or whatever right
so let's say this is
time
[Laughter]
what happens
I don't know I mean this
this will work but if I don't even have
an upper bound that's an interesting
question and for the Federated
everything can I write down my objective
function which is optimized I don't know
um I
I don't maybe you can I just told them
so we didn't we didn't go down that road
to like the mammal update you're
essentially knowing that it's
why are you writing a beat you have an
architecture right mammal works for a
particular architecture so in by doing
that implicitly writing those update
equations is around it's not using
okay
if you do a if you do a
if you do a ultimate algorithm you can
do that that's called credit so we did
work on that few couple of years back we
called federates that we need to know
the right explicitly to solve an
alternating minimization
so that algorithm
was to find B Star and W star and
optimizing example complexity
is it
it seems to work well people use it and
there's a at least one explanation now
if there's a planter representation it's
loving that stuff like this but of
course if they would that's all I'm not
making anything
so when you said okay sample there was
only a statistical question there's no
computational story English
thank you
foreign